la fin du monde apocalypse par une
guerre nucléaire moi une guerre totale
une guerre active
du monde je sais pas mais je parle
jamais à la fin du monde
oui monsieur
le froid le froid le froid et la nuit le
froid et la nuit ça arrangerait bien les
problèmes de mes soucis parce que vous
avez beaucoup de problèmes et pas mal de
soucis
que les gens sont assez intelligents
pour pas pour ne pas détruire la Terre
maintenant c'est comme dans les films
science-fiction c'est tout gris partout
et puis des robots il y a plus personne
plus d'image et les hommes sont mis de
côté et c'est des machines qui photos à
la place des hommes je ne veux pas
partir de la première mais je veux pas
rester la dernière
surtout pas